mientras las tensiones se escalan entre
rusia y occidente y estados unidos
despliega tropas estadounidenses en
europa del este washington acusó a moscú
de organizar una campaña de
desinformación el pentágono dijo que
rusia estaba fabricando un supuesto
ataque del ejército ucraniano como
pretexto para invadir el país vecino one
password raster una posible opción que
los rusos están considerando y que hemos
hecho pública hoy implica la producción
de un vídeo de propaganda un vídeo con
escenas de falsas explosiones con
representación de cadáveres actores de
crisis que simulan ser dolientes e
imágenes de lugares destruidos con
equipamiento militar totalmente
fabricado por la inteligencia rusa en
brasilia o jams los funcionarios
estadounidenses no aportaron ninguna
prueba del supuesto plan y moscú
apresuró a rechazar la acusación
rusia acusa a la casa blanca de escalar
las tensiones especialmente después de
que eeuu anunció el envío de casi 3.000
tropas adicionales a europa del este
según el ministro de defensa de ucrania
actualmente hay 115 mil tropas rusas a
lo largo de las fronteras pero el jueves
dijo que un ataque era poco probable
la inteligencia ucraniana sigue de cerca
los movimientos de las fuerzas armadas
rusas la probabilidad de una escalada
significativa a partir de hoy se
considera baja ya lista mientras tanto
los esfuerzos de mediación internacional
continúan
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
visitará moscú y kiev a principios de la
próxima semana se reunirá con sus
homólogos de rusia y ucrania después de
haber sostenido varias llamadas
telefónicas computing y selenski en los
últimos días